Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzärztin tätig und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das
Aufnahmegespräch führen. Falls Sie Fragen haben, können Sie mich jederzeit unterbrechen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden? Zunächst benötige ich Ihre persönliche Daten.
Wie heißen Sie? Ich heiße Elena Stückemann. Können Sie kurz Ihre Nachname kurzbuchstabieren?
Ja, Stückemann. Wie alt sind Sie Frau Stückemann? Ich bin 36 Jahre alt.
Wie ist Ihre Geburtsdatum? 12. März 1990. Wie groß sind Sie und wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ich bin 1,68 Meter groß und ich wiege 60 Kilo. Frau Stückemann, was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Ja, ich habe seit ungefähr 12 Stunden Bauchschmerzen. Am Anfang waren die Schmerzen
so um den Bauchnabel herum und sind dann aber in den letzten Stunden mehr so in den
rechten Unterbauch gezogen. Okay, also am Anfang war um den Nabel herum. Ja. Okay.
Und jetzt ist es am rechten Unterbauch. Ja. Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer
Skala von 0 bis 10? 6. Können Sie die Schmerzen aushalten oder brauchen Sie dringend?
Ja, die kann ich noch aushalten. Haben Sie schon etwas dagegen eingenommen? Nein,
bis jetzt nicht. Okay. Wie würden Sie die Schmerzen beschreiben Frau Stückemann?
Also der Schmerz ist dauerhaft und mehr drückend. Dauerhaft und drückend. Haben
Sie schon einmal ähnliche Beschwerden gelitten? Nein, das habe ich noch nie gehabt. Strahlen
die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus? Nein. Haben Sie noch andere Beschwerden wie Übelkeit
erbrechen? Also übel ist mir schon, aber bisher habe ich kein Erbrechen. Kein Erbrechen.
Fühlen Sie sich fieprig oder haben Sie Fieber? Vielleicht haben Sie es gemessen.
Ich habe Fieber gemessen vor zwei Stunden. Da hatte ich so etwas über 38, 38,3. Okay,
es war 38,3. Geigen Sie auch unter Schüttelfrost oder Nachschweiß? Nein. Haben Sie Herztrasen
oder Herzstolpern? Nein. Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten mit Wasserlassen oder Stuhlgang?
Wasserlassen ist in Ordnung. Mein letzter Stuhlgang war, schätze ich so vor einem Tag. Gut vor
einem Tag. Ich habe auch sonst immer regelmäßig Stuhlgang. Da habe ich keine Probleme mit.
Keine. Also so eine Durchfall oder Verstopfung, eine Schwierigstuhl? Nein. Okay, super.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit, Frau Stückermann? Normalerweise ist der Appetit gut,
aber seitdem ich jetzt die Bauchschmerzen habe, habe ich nicht viel gegessen, weil mir ist
ja auch etwas übel. Da ist mein Appetit jetzt nicht gut. Okay, seit gestern haben Sie
kein Appetit. Frau Stückermann, gibt es vielleicht einen bestimmten Auslöser für die Schmerzen?
Also haben Sie sowas bemerkt? Vielleicht nach einem bestimmten Nahrungsmittel haben die Schmerzen
auch getreten? Nein, ich habe keine Erklärung dafür. Kann ich Ihnen nichts sagen. Okay.
Gibt es einen betroffenen Seite Hautveränderungen? Nein. Vielleicht Juckreiz,
Hautveränderung, Überwärmung? Nein, habe ich nicht. Ist Ihre Schlaf- Schlafen Sie gut,
Frau Stückermann? Normalerweise schlafe ich ganz gut. Ich habe einen stressigen Beruf. Da
ist es manchmal etwas wechselhaft, aber letzte Nacht habe ich nicht gut geschlafen, weil ich
da die Schmerzen hatte. Wegen die Schmerzen? Ja, ich kann es verstehen. Sie haben auch
nichts dagegen eingenommen. Was machen Sie als Beruflich, Frau Stückermann? Ich bin
Lehrerin. Okay, es ist stresshaft. Ist bei Ihnen chronische Erkrankungen bekannt? Also ich
habe eine Fruchtzuckerunverträglichkeit. Seit einigen Jahren ist das bekannt, aber ich halte eine
Diät und vermeide fruchtzuckerhaltige Sachen, Speisen und damit geht es mir ganz gut. Also
Fruchtzucker, okay. Fruchtzucker, ja. Und ich hatte als junge Erwachsene, da war ich,
23 Jahre alt, da wurde ich häufiger ohnmächtig und habe das Bewusstsein verloren und da hat
man festgestellt, dass ich Herzrhythmusstörungen habe und ich habe dann einen Herzschrittmacher
bekommen mit 23 und seitdem ich den habe, geht es mir gut. Okay, mit 23, dann haben Sie
Herzschrittmacher bekommen. Sonst haben Sie keine Vorerkrankungen. Ist bei Ihnen keine Vorerkrankungen?
Sonst habe ich keine Vorerkrankungen. Okay, außer diese Herzrhythmusstörungen. Okay,
sind Sie schon mal operiert worden? Ja, als Kind, da war ich 10 Jahre alt, da wurde
ich am Leistenbruch operiert. Auf der linken Seite Leistenbruch und mit 20 Jahren hatte ich
einen kleinen Fahrradsturz, Fahrradunfall, da habe ich meinen Knöchel gebrochen. Am
linken Sprunggelenk ist mein Außenknöchel gebrochen und das musste operiert werden.
Außenknöchel, okay, Sprunggelenk. Welche Seite haben Sie gesagt? Links. Links, das auch links?
Ja. Okay, Fahrradunfall haben Sie gesagt. Ja. Okay, alle beide Operationen sind
komplikationslos verlaufen? Ja. Super, super toll. Fröschtücke, man gibt es Medikamente,
besondere Medikamente, die Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf einnehmen? Nein, ich nehme keine
Medikamente ein. Auch nicht bei Bedarf, ich nehme selten Schmerzmittel ein oder so. Selten? Ja. Okay,
das machen wir ja alle schon. Rauchen Sie, Frau Stückemann? Nein. Super. Trinken Sie
Alkohol? Ja, ich trinke mal ein Glas Wein, so am Wochenende vielleicht insgesamt am Wochenende
zwei Glas Wein. Wochenende zwei Gläser Wein, okay. Also kann man sagen, gelegentlich. Ja.
Ja, ich habe noch eine Frage, Frau Stückemann, aber bitte nehmen Sie es nicht persönlich an,
das ist eine Routinfrage. Haben Sie Kontakt mit Drogen? Nein, habe ich nicht. Treiben Sie
Sport regelmäßig oder treiben Sie Sport? Ja, ich bin auch in der Schule Sportlehrerin,
da habe ich dann auch schon meine Bewegung und manchmal, wenn ich Zeit habe, dann jogge
ich auch. Vielleicht einmal pro Woche, aber sonst mache ich eben auch in der Schule viel
Schulsport. Okay, also die bewegen sich jeden Tag. Ja. Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich glaube schon, dass ich die ausreichenden Impfungen habe. Wir haben jetzt in letzter Zeit keine
Fernreisen gemacht oder so, da braucht man jetzt keine Spezialimpfungen, aber die Impfungen
hier für Europa, die habe ich alle, die notwendigen. Okay, also Sie haben schon gesagt,
dass Sie in letzter Zeit keine Fernreisen gemacht haben. Also schon in den letzten sechs Monate
sind Sie schon verreist? Ja, war ich nur einmal in Spanien und auch einmal in Italien,
aber sonst nicht. Okay, also Sie waren innerhalb der Europäischen Union. Ja. Frau Stückermann,
ist in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen bekannt? Also mein Vater, der ist im Alter
von 66 Jahren an Herzinfarkt verstorben. Ah, es tut mir leid zu hören. Ja, da war er 66 und
der hatte vor zehn Jahren hatte mein Vater Prostata Krebs und das wurde operiert seiner
Zeit und bestrahlt, aber davon hat er sich gut erholt. Das war dann ein gutes Ergebnis,
aber wie gesagt, der Herzinfarkt ist ja verstorben. Oh, es tut mir leid. Ja, die Mutter ist 63 Jahre
alt, die hatte vor drei Jahren Eierstock Krebs. Okay. Das wurde auch operiert und sie bekam
anschließend Chemotherapie. Die Nachsorgeuntersuchungen sind bisher, so wie sie mir das berichtet,
gut verlaufen. Ja, sie ist jetzt gut. Ja, bisher ist das gut verlaufen. Die Kontrollen
waren alle gut bisher. Ich habe noch eine Schwester, die ist 36 Jahre alt, die hat
eine Schilddrüsenunterfunktion und muss da ein Medikament nehmen, aber ich kann es
ihnen nicht genau sagen, was sie nimmt, weil sie lebt in einer anderen Stadt. Okay,
das müssen sie auch nicht wissen. Es gibt ja nicht viele Medikamente, nicht so viele
Auswahl bei Schilddrüsenunterfunktionen. Wie alt war ihre Schwester? Meine Schwester
ist jetzt 36. Und die Schilddrüsenunterfunktion ist vielleicht bekannt seit fünf Jahren.
Und sie sind auch 36 Jahre alt? Also meine Schwester ist ein Jahr älter als ich.
Also meine Schwester ist dann 37 Jahre alt und ich bin jetzt gerade 36 geworden im
Okay, falls ich noch nicht den Geburtstag dieses Jahr gehabt habe. Ja, kann man sagen,
sie ist immer noch 36. Okay, Frau Stueckmann, bekommen Sie Ihre Regelblutungen regelmäßig?
Ja, das ist so eine Sache. Also normalerweise bekomme ich die regelmäßig, aber die letzte
Periode war vor sieben Wochen. Die ist jetzt etwas überfällig und ich wollte eigentlich
jetzt nächste Woche zu meiner Gynäkologin und das abklären lassen. Okay, kann es sein,
dass Sie schwanger sind? Das kann theoretisch sein, ja. Das kann theoretisch sein. Nehmen
Sie Pille ein für Verhütung oder? Nein, nein, wir verhütten mit Spirale eigentlich.
Okay, wie ist Ihre Familienstandfrau? Verheiratet. Stueckmann, ja. Sie sind verheiratet. Haben
Sie schon Kinder? Ja, eine Tochter. Eine Tochter, die ist fünf Jahre alt. Okay, sehr schön. Ist
sie gesund? Ja. Super. Okay, also wir werden auch natürlich die Schwangerschaft auch
kontrollieren. Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen, Frau Stueckmann? Nein, ich glaube,
es ist soweit alles besprochen worden. Ja, also ich wollte noch etwas fragen, aber das fällt mir
jetzt nicht ein. Das eine Auslöser. Ja, das fällt mir jetzt nicht ein. Wenn es mir einfällt,
kann ich während der Kopperlich-Untersuchung noch nachfragen. Ja, okay. Ja, kann man schon so
machen. Gut. Ja. Gut. Ja, also Frau Stueckmann, ich muss jetzt meine Oberarzt
Bescheid geben. Dann kurz komme ich wieder zurück, um die körperliche Untersuchungen und
die anderen Verfahren durchzuführen. Ich komme wieder gleich zurück. Okay, das können wir so
machen. Gut, danke. Dann haben Sie jetzt etwas Zeit, sich vorzubereiten, die Patientensprache
zu übersetzen. Kolleginnen und Kollegen, heute Abend sind es ja recht viele, haben vielleicht
noch eine Frage oder begänzende Fragen. Ja, ich mache das. Also man könnte natürlich jetzt
eine kurze Zusammenfassung machen noch am Ende dieser Anamnese und kurz sagen, Frau Stueckmann,
ich möchte kurz zusammenfassen und Sie können mich gerne korrigieren, wenn ich etwas nicht
richtig sage. Sie sind hier zu uns gekommen, weil Sie seit ungefähr zwölf Stunden Bauchschmerzen
haben. Diese Bauchschmerzen haben um den Nabel herum angefangen und sind in den letzten
Stunden mehr in den rechten Unterbauch gezogen. Die Schmerzen strahlen nicht aus. Sie haben
etwas erhöhte Temperatur bzw. Fieber gemessen mit 38,3. Wo haben Sie gemessen? Oral.
Patientin hat oral gemessen. Sie haben etwas Übelkeit, aber kein Erbrechen. Solche Schmerzen
haben Sie bisher noch nie gehabt. Und sonst fühlen Sie sich eigentlich ganz gesund. Sie
haben berichtet, dass Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen eine Fruchtzuckerunverträglichkeit
haben. Und Sie haben seit dem 23. Lebensjahr einen Herzschrittmacher wegen Herzrhythmusstörungen
und Ohnmachtsanfällen, die Sie damals hatten. Das wäre so erstmal die wesentlichen Dinge,
die man vielleicht zusammenfassend am Ende nochmal sagen kann. Man muss jetzt nicht alles
nochmal wiederholen wie die Familienanamnese oder alle Operationen. Und dann kann Frau
Stücke mal sagen, ja das stimmt so. Oder dass Sie vielleicht, sonst fällt ihr vielleicht
noch etwas ein. Das ist manchmal auch wichtig, dass der Patientin vielleicht noch ein etwas
Wichtiges einfällt. Aber die Patientin sagt, nein das ist alles so korrekt und das wäre noch
ein Vorschlag, wenn Sie Zeit haben in der Anamnese. Ja das wollte ich jetzt fragen.
Die Zeit läuft jetzt erst glaube ich in einer Minute ab. Was ich hier oben in der laufenden Uhr sehe,
das ist immer ganz praktisch für mich. Gibt es von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch andere,
gäbe es noch andere Fragen? Ja sie haben schon auch für mich die Vorstellung gemacht.
Ich habe aber noch keine Fachbegriffe benutzt. Ja. Also die Kolleginnen und Kollegen sind
offenkundig zufrieden mit Ihnen, mit Ihrer Befragung, sodass jetzt offenkundig keine
weiteren Fragen mehr. Ja darf ich? Ja bitte, ja bitte. Haben Sie bemerkt,
etwas Ihre Beschwerden verhindert oder versteckt? Also ich darf nicht auf den Bauch
drauf drücken. Druck ist nicht gut auf dem Bauch. Oder wenn ich eine, ich habe versucht,
eine etwas engere Hose, einen Gürtel zu tragen, das ist nicht gut. Druck ist nicht gut.
Am besten, ich habe mich am besten lieber auf das Sofa gelegt, auf den Rücken und habe mich
ruhig verhalten. Das ist das Beste. Haben Sie Schmerzen seit zwei Stunden, richtig? Seit
zwölf Stunden. Zwölf. Zwölf, verzeihen. Zwölf Stunden, ja. Ja okay. Am Anfang war der
Schmerz am Bauchnabel und ist dann in den rechten Bauch, Unterbauch gezogen. Okay,
danke. Darf ich fragen, sind die Schmerzen plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten? Langsam.
Langsam, okay. Und leiden Sie unter Virginiae im Ausfluss? Nein, habe ich nicht beobachtet.
Okay. Haben Sie Unterbauchschmerzen vor und während der Periode? Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Da habe ich eigentlich keine Probleme mit. Okay, danke schön. Darf ich? Ja bitte. Haben
Sie in den letzten sechs Monaten Ungewollt ab oder zu genommen? Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht,
glaube ich, gehalten. Da ist mir nichts aufgefallen. Danke. Haben Sie Erbrochen? Nein,
ich habe nur Übelkeit. Kein Erbrochen. Haben Sie Vollgefühl, Aufstossen bemerkt? Nein,
nein. Es ist mir nicht aufgefallen. Ist diese Schmerzen das erste Mal oder haben Sie
früher ähnliche Beschwerden? Nein, diese Schmerzen kenne ich nicht. Die habe ich so noch
nie gehabt. Gut, ich lasse Sie jetzt mal noch einige Minuten alleine, dann können Sie sich
besser konzentrieren. Entschuldigung, ich habe andere Fragen außer diesem Falle. Wollte ich
jetzt fragen oder nach der Vorstellung fragen? Machen wir lieber nach der Vorstellung. Ja,
gut. Hallo, guten Tag Herr Dr. Oberarzt. Ich habe eine neue Patienten aufgenommen. Ich
würde Sie gerne vorstellen, falls Sie Zeit haben. Ja, habe ich. Also die 36-jährige
Frau Elena Stueckermann ist 1,68 Meter groß und wiegt 60 Kilogramm. Frau Stueckermann
stellte sich heute bei uns wegen seit 12 Stunden bestehenden dauerhaften, langsam
aufgetretenen, drückenden rechten Unterbauchschmerzen vor. Sie berichtet,
dass die Schmerzen um den Umbilikus angefangen haben und nach sechs Stunden
zur rechten Unterbauch gewandert haben. Okay, also haben das sehr gut eingeleitet. Ich würde
vielleicht sagen, Frau Stueckermann berichtet seit, dass sie seit 12 Stunden Abdominalschmerzen
habe, die um umbilikal begonnen haben, langsam umbilikal begonnen haben und dann im
Verlaufe der Zeit in den rechten Unterbauch oder in die rechte Fossa iliaca, also rechte
Unterbauch gezogen sind. Der Schmerz wird als dumpf und erdrückend beschrieben und auf der
VAE-Skala mit Stärke 6. So kann man das vielleicht auch schreiben. Also umbilikal begonnen
und dann in den Unterbauch gezogen, von der Chronologie her. Ja, also das ist auf jeden
Fall besser. Ja, aber das erste war auch schon gut. Danke. Also wie Sie schon gesagt
haben, die Schmerzen liegen bei 6 von 10 auf eine Schmerzkala und die Schmerzen
verschlechtern sind, wenn man drückt, wenn man in den rechten Unterbauch drückt. Zu
den Schmerzen begleitet no ser. Ja, die Schmerzen seien ohne Ausstrahlung. Das habe ich vergessen
zu hinzufügen. Ja, die Fragen also nach Erbrochen, Herzstörungen wurden verneint.
Sagen Sie ruhig, es besteht Nausea ohne Emesis. Nausea ohne Emesis, weil das ist
oft immer ein Zusammenhang. Dann wird gefragt, dann fragt der Oberarzt, hat die
Patientin erbrochen, weil sie sagen, es besteht Nausea. Dann sagen Sie ruhig, es besteht Nausea
ohne Emesis. Dann hat man diesen Komplex abgehandelt. Gut, hat die Patientin Fieber?
Ja, sie habe Fieber. Sie habe es vor zwei Stunden oral gemessen und hat es 38,3 Grad
festgestellt. Okay. Sie leide seit gestern unter Inapetens und schmerzbedingte Insomnie.
Okay. Sonst ist die vegetative Anamnese unauffällig. Sagen Sie ruhig vielleicht
nochmal bewusst dazu, unauffällige Miktion und unauffällige Defekation. Oder letzter
Stuhlgang vor ungefähr 18 Stunden und unauffällig ist, oder Miktion unauffällig.
Das Ausdruck, dass Sie es auch gefragt haben. Das ist gut. Ja, das ist ja spannend. Hat die
Patientin chronische Erkrankungen? Ja, die Patientin leide an einer Herzrhythmusstörung.
Ja, ich denke, eine Fachbegriff, aber das ist eine Herzrhythmusstörung. Muss man nicht
unbedingt sagen. Das kann wer weiß was sein. Es gibt Six-Sinus-Syndrome oder Sinus-Blockierungen
oder Wolf-Parkinson-White oder was die Leute haben, die zu einer Syncope führen. Jedenfalls
sagen Sie es ruhig, seit wann oder in welchem Alter das war? Also es ist festgestellt,
es sei festgestellt, im Alter von 23 Jahren und sie habe deswegen einen Herzschrittmacher
bekommen und seitdem ist alles okay bei ihr. Man kann sagen, aufgrund von Herzrhythmusstörungen
mit Syncope, sie ist ja Synkopal gewesen, wurde ein Herzschrittmacher implantiert,
seitdem ist die Patientin beschwerdefrei. Was hat die Patientin noch für chronische
Erkrankungen? Sie leide auch an Fructosintoleranz. Fructosintoleranz und es sei mit Diät behandelt.
Okay, gut. Bei Frau Stueckmann wurde im Alter von zehn Jahren eine linkseitige Inguinalhernie-Operation
durchgeführt. Ja, man kann auch sagen eine Herniotomie.
Eine Herniotomie durchgeführt. Das wäre nochmal das komplette, aber die Operation ist in Ordnung
wegen einer linkseitigen Inguinalhernie. Das war wichtig, das haben Sie sehr gut gesagt.
Okay, danke. Und im Alter von 20 Jahren sei bei Frau Stueckmann eine linkseitige
Sprung wegen einer linkseitigen Sprünkelenkfraktur aufgrund von Fahrradunfall eine Operation
durchgeführt worden. Sie hat gesagt der linke Außenknöchel, das wäre wahrscheinlich
eine Distale-Fibula-Fraktur in dem Bereich, also Sprünkelenk-OSG. Gut, und das wurde
auch mit Osteosynthese versorgt. Ja, Osteosynthese. Okay, gut. Können Sie noch mehr berichten
über die Familie? Ja, ich möchte erst über die Noxen berichten. Sie sei nicht Braucherin und
sie trinke gelegentlich Alkohol, also ungefähr zwei Gläser am Wochenende. Sie habe keinen
Kontakt mit Drogen und sie treibt regelmäßig Sport. Sie ist eine Sportlehrerin und
ist körperlich, sie bewegt sich körperlich jeden Tag in der Schule. Okay. Und außerdem joggt
sie. Sie sei vollständig geimpft und bis auf eine Spanien- und Italienreise sei die Reise
an der Amnese unauffällig. Der Vater von Frau Stöckermann sei im Alter von 66 Jahren an einem
Myokadinfaktus gestorben und vorher habe er zehn Jahre lang an Prostatkarzinom gelitten.
Die Mutter sei leider an einem Ovariankarzinom seit drei Jahren und es wurde mit Operationen und
Chemotherapie behandelt. Okay. Und die Schwester leider an einer Hypothyrose. Okay, gut. Ja.
Frau Stöckermann sei verheiratet, sie habe eine gesunde Tochter und wie ich schon gesagt habe,
sie arbeitet als Sportlehrerin. Sie bekommt ihre Menstruation regelmäßig,
aber sie habe ihre letzte Menstruation vor sieben Wochen bekommen und sie war noch nicht bei
ihrem Frauenarzt, bei ihrem Gynäkologe wegen dieser Station. Okay. Aber Frau Stöckermann
hat gesagt, ich werde nächste Woche, möchte ich gerne zur Gynäkologin. Ja, okay. Gut. Ja,
das habe ich jetzt erstmal viele Informationen bekommen. Was ist denn Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose?
Ja, also die anamnistischen Angaben, also sprechen für eine Appendicitis und
Differentialdiagnostik kommen, also eine Ovarialtorsion, vielleicht eine Colizistitis,
vielleicht Ileus und vielleicht eine Divertikulitis. Okay. Divertikulitis würden
wir wahrscheinlich eher im linken Unterbauch erwarten? Ja, höchstwahrscheinlich ist
die Appendicitis einverstanden. Und Gynäkologisch? Also Ovarialtorsion kommt in
meinen Betracht. Eine Extrauterin-Gravität? Ja, genau, eine Extrauterin-Gravität. Ja,
das würde ich eventuell... Das sollte am ersten Blick... Differential an erster Stelle stehen,
ausbleibende Periode vor sieben Wochen, letzte Menstruation, zumindest unklar. Eine
Kollegin hatte noch nach Fluor gefragt, Fluor genitalis, das liegt wohl nicht vor. Was dann...
Manchmal ist ja eine Anexitis vielleicht auch mit im Spiel, dann gibt es vielleicht noch
andere Begleitsymptome. Aber zumindest Verdacht auf Appendicitis natürlich,
da wird natürlich an einen Gynäkologischen Prozess. Das würde ich sagen, sind die
beiden Hauptpunkte, die es jetzt abzuklären gilt. A, durch eine körperliche Untersuchung,
vielleicht durch ein gynäkologisches Konzil, je nachdem wie die Klinik ausgestattet ist. Und
natürlich letztendlich auch durch dann ergänzende Labouruntersuchung bzw. Abdominalsonographie.
Klar. Aber gut. Erstmal vielen Dank. Das haben Sie wieder sehr gut gemacht, finde ich. Sie
haben das sehr strukturiert gefragt und ich habe Sie gut verstanden. Und Sie haben auch die
Grammatik denke ich gut eingesetzt. Bei der Körpergröße brauchen Sie nicht sagen, sagen Sie
ruhig entweder 1,68 Meter. Das ist gängig. Sie können auch sagen 168 Zentimeter groß. Aber
in Deutschland wird meist gesagt 1,68 Meter. 1,68 Meter. Dazwischen gibt es keinen Grund.
1,68 Meter groß. Aber sonst denke ich haben Sie auch die Fachbegriffe sehr gut gebracht.
Da kam es schon mal drauf an. Ob Nausea oder Emesis oder Fructoseintoleranz. Manche sagen
Fructoseunverträglichkeit. Das wäre die erworbene Fructose. Die Intoleranz ist ja oft
angeboren bei Kindern leider. Da muss man gucken. Aber Fructoseintoleranz ist in Ordnung.
Das kann man durchaus sagen. Myokatinfarkt, Prostata-Karzinom, Ovarialkarzinom,
Hypothyriose. Diese Dinge haben Sie denke ich alle gut ohne Probleme in Ihrem Repertoire.
Das ist gut. Ja. Und wann ist jetzt Ihre Prüfung? Am Montag. Sie haben mir das
schon mal gesagt. Ja, das ist die zweite Simulation mit Ihnen. Also die erste war
eigentlich nicht so gut. Ich war nicht so konzentriert. Das fand ich schon. Und die ist
in Karlsruhe oder wo ist das? Ja, in Karlsruhe. Irgendwes habe ich da noch in Erinnerung.
Ja, Karlsruhe. Und am Montag. Ja, da werden Sie ganz, wenn Sie da so schön ruhig bleiben
wie jetzt und dann haben Sie das drauf. Sie kriegen das gut hin. Vielen Dank. Mit
Ihrer Hilfe. Ich würde jetzt sagen viel Erfolg erst mal für Ihre Prüfung und bedanke mich bei
den Teilnehmerinnen.